[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi ricordate a scuola poco prima
dell'intervallo che si era un po' tutti
e l'insegnante effettivamente alla fine
finiva la lezione però poi faceva la
domanda
qualcuno di voi forse ha dei dubbi
E puntualmente
cascasse il mondo
c'era il secchione della classe che
alzava la mano
Ecco Quel secchione ero io
frot Twist Come farsi odiare in un
tedesco in circa 10 secondi fatto Vabbè
dai ma poi mi facevo perdonare aiutavo
quei compiti con con gli appunti Insomma
vedo qualcuno che annuisce forse sono
stato perdonato Vabbè Scherzi a parte
una volta usciti dalla scuola e
dall'università e dovendo affrontare
concretamente la vita spesso ci siamo
reso conto resi conto di quante
competenze in realtà di quante
conoscenze non sono utili ma
fondamentali per affrontare
concretamente l'esistenza non
conoscessimo non sapessimo fare
cos'è un'assicurazione Come si paga un
Come si fa un mutuo Come si affronta
emotivamente la fine di una relazione
oppure come si contatta un avvocato Come
si ripara un lavandino ragazzi come si
ripara un lavandino
è così ci siamo ritrovati a dover
chiedere a questo a quell'amico parente
a mio cugino oppure a informarci qui e
lì ma facendo un immane fatica Insomma
terminati i percorsi scolastici
tradizionali spesso e volentieri ci
siamo resi conto di magari di avere
tante nozioni alcune utili efficaci
valide interessanti ma di essere
profondamente ignoranti su tantissime
cose fondamentali per la nostra
esistenza per sopravvivere
E questo dovrebbe farci riflettere sul
ruolo della scuola sulla sua funzione
sulla sua finalità
Al di là poi delle esperienze personali
ci sono tanti dati sulla scuola che in
parte ci potrebbero fare preoccupare ve
ne ho portati alcuni
il primo
più del 50% dei nostri studenti in
Italia mentre studia provoca cioè prova
un forte stress
il dato in 6 per sè già importante ma la
media oxe quindi la media dei paesi su
cui è stata fatta la ricerca è molto più
bassa la stessa cosa si vede per un
altro dato cioè l'ansia Prima di una
verifica prima di un test anche se i
nostri studenti sono molto Preparati
provo una provano ansia nel 70% dei casi
contro una media di 15 punti più o meno
Inferiore
se si prende un campione rappresentativo
e si chiede Qual è il principale
problema della scuola italiana nel 52%
dei casi ed è il dato più alto la
risposta è programmi obsoleti e troppo
teorici andiamo avanti
purtroppo più di un giovane su 10 in
Italia abbandona la scuola prima della
maggiore età e quindi prima di
concludere le superiori
è tanto è il 13% è uno dei dati più alti
d'Europa
andiamo su con l'età
tra i 20 e i 29 anni un giovane su tre
considerabile un neet è una persona che
non lavora non segue percorsi di
educazione né di formazione
e tutti questi dati messi insieme
portano all'ultimo
quasi un italiano su tre è considerabile
un analfabeta funzionale anche in questo
caso Cosa vuol dire
un analfabeta funzionale una persona che
ha difficoltà e magari non riesce
proprio a recuperare
capire e comprendere e utilizzare le
informazioni che tutti i giorni riceve
dalla realtà in cui vive
Insomma è una panoramica Abbastanza
drammatica ma vi devo dire la verità
prima di fare il divulgatore ho fatto
l'insegnante E anche gli insegnanti
purtroppo non ridono per tutta una serie
di ragioni ad esempio
anche se ci sono alcuni insegnanti che
vogliono innovare spesso e volentieri i
programmi sono talmente vasti tutti
siamo stati a scuola no che quasi
impossibile riuscire a fare innovazione
bisogna seguire una scaletta ordinata di
eventi e di informazioni e di argomenti
in modo antico noioso Il rischio è
quello con scarso ancoraggio alla
contemporaneità alla pratica veniamo al
punto nel 2023 la scuola italiana così
com'è È davvero sostenibile
Non dovete rispondere è una domanda
retorica ovviamente ci sarebbero
tantissime cose da fare a 360 gradi
servirebbe una riforma strutturale della
scuola magari da diciamo
integrare nel nostro ordinamento in modo
graduale In modo tale che il cambiamento
sia progressivo ci si riesca ad abituare
ma che sia rivoluzionaria nei contenuti
e per fare questo ci vogliono i soldi
quindi bisognerebbe investire almeno il
5% del PIL che è la media europea che si
investe nell'educazione mentre in Italia
in Italia siamo intorno al 3-4% a
seconda degli anni
Ora noi qua non è che possiamo fare in
10 minuti la riforma della scuola
rivoluzionaria Però possiamo indicare in
termini di impostazione della scuola in
termini di temi da trattare le
competenze gli strumenti che potrebbero
portarci a una scuola sostenibile e qual
è secondo me una scuola sostenibile
vi ricordate a scuola Io spero che tutti
voi abbiano vissuto una situazione del
genere c'era Quel professore
che ho anche se l'argomento non vi
piaceva mi faceva appassionare di tutto
vi prendeva in considerazione vi metteva
in discussione vi permetteva di
esprimervi Ecco una riforma strutturale
della scuola dovrebbe permettere Che
esperienza di questo tipo tra docenti e
alunni siano una normalità accadano
quotidianamente
una scuola sostenibile Secondo me è una
scuola che insegna a diventare maestri
di se stessi
i quali sono le competenze e gli
strumenti per arrivare a questo
obiettivo ne ho selezionati 5
Il primo è il pensiero critico in un
mondo sempre più pervaso da fake news
Deep fake notizie create
dall'intelligenza artificiale o immagini
è fondamentale riuscire ad avere un
minimo di giudizio di oggettività per di
fronte a un fatto un evento
un'informazione riuscire a discernere se
queste informazioni è falsa è vera
quanto meno ad avere un'idea il pensiero
critico è fondamentale per renderci
consapevoli e liberi
consapevoli e liberi di pensare e
consapevoli e liberi di agire
poi c'è la dualità l'ancoraggio alla
qualità un maggior ancoraggio
all'attualità perché una volta terminata
la scuola lo studente deve essere
autonomo semiautonomo non dovrebbe quasi
più avere bisogno di nessuno o comunque
dovrebbe avere gli strumenti per
cavarsela da solo
e quindi arriviamo alle nozioni
Ma partendo dalla contemporaneità E
facciamolo in modo multidisciplinare
perché la realtà non è unica è una sola
si può approcciare con tante prospettive
diverse e variopinta che poi è anche il
suo bello vi faccio un esempio
ipotizziamo di essere in una quarta
superiore e una quinta superiore
e quindi siamo lì siamo per finire la
scuola non vediamo l'ora però poi
guardiamo i giornali i telegiornali e
vediamo che improvvisamente un tot di
studenti universitari cominciano a
piazzare la tenda fuori dalle università
italiane
Insomma un po' di preoccupazione ci
viene
perché pare che gli affitti siano
talmente alti in certe Metropoli che si
rischia di venir meno al diritto allo
scudo allo studio Ecco quanto sarebbe
bello che una scuola che nella scuola
esistesse proprio un tempo da dedicare
all'approfondimento di notizie di questo
tipo che magari non prenda spazio al
programma oppure il programma è
modulabile in funzione
dell'approfondimento di questo tipo di
notizie perché Pensateci analizzando una
notizia del genere quante informazioni
in più Gli studenti potrebbero ricevere
su Che cos'è un affitto Come si paga su
quali sono le leggi della domanda e
dell'offerta su come sono strutturate le
nostre università le nostre città sui
diritti civili e sociali
E quindi direttamente connessa la
pratica un maggiore ancoraggio alla
pratica e anche in questo caso vi faccio
due esempi stavolta più rapidi studiamo
la chimica ad esempio partendo
dall'analisi della merendina o del
frutto che ci portiamo all'intervallo
posto che ci sia il laboratorio a scuola
questo è un altro discorso
e studiamo la matematica in modo
applicato quindi non studiando gli
integrali
No studiamola in modo applicato la
matematica cominciamo a imparare a
gestire una paghetta un risparmio
insegniamo magari già a investire
aumentiamo l'educazione finanziaria dei
nostri studenti
quarto ambito le relazioni relazioni ed
emozioni
una scuola sostenibile è una scuola
ragazzi il primo la prima indicazione
nei nelle offerte di lavoro è saper
lavorare in team tutti tutti ce li hanno
Ecco la scuola deve creare un ambiente
fertile per questo tipo di cose e quindi
deve
insegnare agli studenti a relazionarsi
tra loro a confrontarsi e quindi
progetti di gruppo ricerca e di gruppo
dibattiti esposizioni giochi di ruolo
comunicazione reciproca di emozioni e
pensieri ci sono tanti docenti che in
realtà già lo fanno eh
però di nuovo in una riforma quindi
dovendo indicare delle linee guida per
una riforma della scuola dobbiamo
rendere situazioni del genere la
normalità
e infine la creatività
l'ultimo punto fondamentale
per diventare maestri di se stessi per
insegnare a diventare maestri di se
stessi è fondamentale che la scuola
punti sulla creatività individuale e
sulle qualità individuali ma non solo
sostenendole
potenziandole e quindi se in classe
abbiamo uno studente particolarmente
dotato un fenomeno in laboratorio di
cucina e che vuole fare lo chef più che
soffermarci magari su altre lacune che
ha in altre discipline
puntiamo fortemente su quella passione
su quella capacità e permettiamo a quel
talento di esprimersi e di diventare una
professione
Grazie mille
[Applauso]